i think we're generally so excited we
see the hard work that goes into each
person's business being generous with
helping people like it does come back to
you like there's room for everyone it's
just like i think the motto that we've
always had well according to kim
kardashian there's room for everyone in
business but how about in the
kardashians new hulu show just tune in
because you never know what's going to
happen in a new profile for variety
spotlighting kris jenner and her
daughters kim courtney and khloe
kardashian
it was revealed that caitlyn jenner who
was a staple on keeping up with the
kardashians from 2007 to 2021
will not be appearing in the fam's new
show but no hard feelings no i was very
actually i was very happy because now
katelyn is making it clear on twitter
she's happy for her fam's continued
success i don't think you have to worry
about the family they're going to be
just fine the former olympian retweeted
variety story with a sweet message
quote i was there when this started from
day one i watched it grow and doing the
show for almost 20 seasons was one of
the highlights of my life to be able to
work with my family for all those years
it was incredible happy that it
continues for my family those things
i'll miss
you know
yeah i'll miss those times because yeah
it was great
of course caitlyn was a mainstay on
keeping up i just really feel like over
the last year and a half we certainly
have grown apart as that series came to
an end in 2021 caitlyn reflected on all
those years sharing her life with the
cameras over 10 years i did the show i
really enjoyed doing the show yeah um
really brought my family very close
together we went through a lot together
i think i have probably some of the best
conversations with my kids on camera it
was a great experience great experience
and that's the only thing i see the end
of the show um is it's kind of you know
sad but
all my kids every one of them you know
even not just the ones on the show but
all my other children that i have
i couldn't be more proud they've all
been very successful they've all worked
very hard great work ethics and they're
really good people so that's the most
important thing the series gave a true
look inside the family's lives a
commitment kim says they made long ago
from the start we decided that we always
wanted to be really open and honest to
who we are when we would film tough
episodes that were really about our life
whether it was breakups or
transitions or things that other people
might be having a hard time dealing with
at home if that changed the way that
reality tv is you know viewed or seen as
being really helpful and informational i
think that makes me proud and will carry
into their new hulu show
can you believe this is day one
literally this is insane
i love us
this makes me so happy
she's never had a reaction like that for
me and it's happened like a few times
we really have no restrictions before on
e it was
totally us and totally amazing but the
episodes were so short and the producers
definitely knew what the audience wanted
and this feels a little bit more
documentary style coming from a
different angle of where we're at in our
lives now because it's different sides
[Music]
you